okay
um my name is captain christine buest
it's k-r-i-s-t-i-n-e
last name is b-u-i-s-t
i'm the southeast area command captain
today i'm here to brief you on an
incident that we had in the close
proximity to the high school here
at approximately 11 o'clock this morning
school police received a report that
there was a small fire on the campus
here at the high school
as a precaution they evacuated the
students and staff from the high school
while the fire was dealt with
they then were able to escort the
students and staff back inside
at approximately 11 43 hours
lvpd dispatch received multiple phone
calls for
shots fired heard in the area
as well as a potential victim
lvmpd units responded to the area and
quickly located a scene
the scene is near the school however it
did not occur on school property
no victims were initially located in the
area
and units began canvassing for witnesses
victims or any video that may have been
available
while units were on scene they began
receiving calls from a local hospital
that there were victims that were being
dropped off with gunshot wounds
units responded to the hospital and were
able to determine that there are three
victims
the victims are being treated at that
hospital
two have been determined to be victim or
i apologize to be students at the school
this is currently being investigated by
the lvmpd gang unit in conjunction with
clark county school police
we're still in the process of
investigating
obviously this is very very preliminary
and we have just started the
investigation so i don't have any
additional information on that so you
have three shooting victims and two are
students
three victims two are confirmed to be
students here through school police have
they given you any info on whether these
are life-threatening injuries they're
being treated at local hospitals i don't
have any updated information on the
status would it be inaccurate to call
this a school shooting it did not occur
on school property
um we do not believe that the the fire
incident is going to be related to this
however it did give the opportunity that
they were off campus when they were
evacuated
okay
three victims two are students is one an
adult
i i don't have any additional on the
third victim okay okay thank you